um as much as you need him as much as we
need to
and send you guys updates as much as
possible and so we want to start this
process
um today so we appreciate you coming um
this this um briefing is going to be
with
the mayor elliot as well as
the acting city manager reggie edwards
and so it's just going to be them to
they're going to both have some brief
statements
they're going to take some questions we
hope to have you out of here
in 30 minutes is that okay
okay so i think they're here
i will run the q a afterwards after they
finish their statements
i want everybody to have a chance and
if you get two chances that's fine but
you know there's a lot of people in here
so
general topic of their statement for
yeah i know you guys probably want a
reaction to um
the charges so i'm sure that will come
we also are doing some things in the
community that we want to update
on you on um that they've been working
with different community leaders to try
to get some help
during this crisis from the community
and even though i stalled
yeah is that okay at least you know at
least you know
who the deal is right and what the deal
is
i can't imagine how busy you guys are
how tired you are so
appreciate it
i didn't i never used to say that when i
was at minneapolis public schools so i
can say that now
right sheila right
a lot more relaxed
um
great so we're going to start i know we
don't have a lot of time
i've already spoken to
to the media about why i'm here what i'm
doing um
and so i'm not going to waste any more
time
like i said we have the assistant the
acting assistant
not assistant the acting
city manager but i keep saying assistant
right the acting city manager
reggie edwards and we have our our mayor
here
and um mayor elliot like i said they're
gonna have some comments
we're gonna take some q a i'll be back
for that and um let's get started
thank you stan good afternoon um
welcome thank you for coming out to
hear our story today let me start i just
want to make two points and then i'll
pass it on to the mayor
we are of course aware of the decision
of the washington county
attorney to charge former brooklyn
senate police officer
kimberly potter with second degree
manslaughter
and the death of dante wright last
sunday
because the officer former officer
parter is no longer an employee of the
city the city does not have an official
position
on that issue let me say that
today we had an inaugural meeting of a
very important
group i want to announce the formation
of the brooklyn center community crisis
team
which is about nine members at this
particular point of the developing
um team representative of businesses
faith
education non-profit and city government
we will meet daily for the next 10 days
in order to assure coordination as the
city moves forward
this is a new way of us trying to
create a path going forward it's a new
opportunity for us to bridge
relationships and to share understanding
perspectives and gain
insights from those um outside the walls
of city government that can help us
shape again
how we move forward on behalf of the
community as well as the city
and do that collectively as one
so we had our inaugural meeting as i
mentioned today and i appreciate and
look forward to that partnership
as we try to make the city better and
stronger a place for all residents
there are three focuses of that group
each day we come together we ask three
fundamental basic questions one
what happened at the protest yesterday
and we tried to learn
and to try to see what that looked like
and how that experience was
from the eyes of those around the table
so again that's no longer the city
looking at the protests from the city
lands
or simply community from community lands
we're sharing those and gaining insights
from each other
so as we ask about what happened
yesterday then we asked the question how
does it form what we will do today
so today we're taking on and trying to
do things that are a little bit
different
than we did yesterday and keeping it
safe for example we increased
communication now that we have community
community coordinating with our officers
we're able to say well let's share phone
numbers and let's simply
talk when you see something happening
you can communicate with us when we know
something we can communicate with you
it's a small step but it's something
that would not have happened
had we not start coming together working
together as a team and the final thing
is
as we think about what we do tonight
we're planning to see of how we move
forward
we understand that this will not change
overnight relationships will not be
built overnight
trust will not be built overnight but as
we come together as we share as we
understand
and as we work together and create
successful practices and opportunities
we will get better in the long haul and
that's where our systemic change will
come
so i appreciate that i appreciate you
coming in tonight with that said i'll
have the mayor come forward to share his
um thoughts
good afternoon i want to thank
the residents of brooklyn center and the
broader twin city community
and this country for gathering these
last few days
and for raising your voices in honor of
dante wright
this has truly been a tragic and
difficult week
for the people of brooklyn center
and my heart is broken for dante's
family
and friends he was taken from us
and from them far too soon
[Applause]
i share our community's anger
and sadness and shock
and my message to all who are demanding
justice for him
and for his family is this
your voices have been heard
now the eyes of the world are watching
brooklyn center
and i urge you
to protest peacefully and without
violence
let us show the best of our community
and to the right family i know that
there is
nothing i can say or do
that will bring dante back
or ease your grief but i promise you
this
his death will not go in vain
and as we navigate this challenge
we are going to strive to ensure the
safety of our residents
and our staff including our public
safety officers
and we are working to safeguard our
businesses
and other gathering places from damage
with the news of the decision to charge
the former brooklyn center
police officer with manslaughter comes a
prolonged
period of continued grieving hurt
and understandable anger
our task as a city
and as a leadership is to allow for the
expression of those
very legitimate voices
and to also create a pathway forward
toward healing and renewal
of our stability and strength as a
community
the foundations of achieving these goals
are transparency
and accountability i look forward to
working with
our city council and
our newly established community crisis
management team
and with all of our residents
that find uh together with all of our
residents to find a way forward
and i ask the community to remain
peaceful
as we live through this tragic event
and i pledge my support to
honor the request for justice for dante
wright as he and his family remain
in our thoughts i want to reiterate
that we have extended the curfew
from 10 p.m to 6 a.m tonight
here in brooklyn center i want to thank
you all and
we'll stand for questions
[Music]
will the former officer get her pension
and any uh
retirement happens that she's a career
the officer has um did resign and with
that comes the obligation of
for it to be entitled to all the crude
in all benefits that is due
who is on the crisis team who are the
people can you name them and how many
are they and do any of them live in
brooklyn center
yes some do at this time i'm not um in a
position to share those names because
it's still
forming so as that team forms we do
anticipate having a press conference
where we can introduce
individual members and we can also share
that list after use
as that team um again
that have been forms these meetings in
the last few days
if their community members um i can only
say that there are some
who are community members who's in
charge department
right now who's making the decision to
department and also
who's in charge of the police force that
is controlling protesters can you break
that down for the public
i can answer that sure all right um
the uh brooklyn center police department
uh reports to the mayor's office
and so uh i am in charge of the police
department
and to your uh question
uh about uh who's leading the
active operation at this
well last night's operation was led by
the sheriff's office and uh
you know he led a combined uh force
from uh of regional uh partners
uh in responding to this crisis
again so you know the the
operation itself was led by the
sheriff's office that's an important
question to ask
they hadn't begun the charity question
right over here you know we've seen
unrest we've also seen calls for
peaceful protests in the past and we've
heard that
community members have been reached out
to so they can share that message as
well how is this different and how do we
expect this to work
i'm sorry can you repeat your question
so i can understand it
and answer it well with the new
community response
crisis team how is this different and
how is the message
to demonstrators going is going to be
heard
so that these process stay peaceful
well you know it's it's our goal to make
sure that uh people continue to be heard
the community crisis team has been
assembled is one way of making sure that
uh the grievances that people are
putting forward are
you know channel in a way that we can
hear and address those grievances
and uh i mean i don't know uh dr edwards
did you have more to add to that
i can only say that we are formulating
those
um strategies so again as i mentioned
today
just today as it relates to improving
our communication
that will hopefully deliver greater
safety
and better coordination than they did
yesterday as we meet tomorrow we will
have
additional strategies again we're
meeting for the next 10 days
every day so it's our job and what we're
tasked with is to come up with those
options with those ideas and those
strategies so i'm not sure what all
strategies have been done in other parts
of the country and other places of civil
unrest
but we are endeavored to try to be as
innovative and creative as we can
to create those opportunities from safe
and peaceful demonstration
here in brooklyn center is the city of
brooklyn center self-insured or do you
have
other liability insurance given that
a lawsuit in this situation is highly
probable
so to the to to the best of my knowledge
right now uh to answer your question
uh we are part of a um
uh the league of minnesota cities
uh insurance uh program and so
uh you know we're we're insured uh
through that
you know collective uh uh
insurance pool of cities is there any is
any help
or relief of any kind being given to the
families who
live in the apartment building across
the street and here by the police
department who
had tear gas canisters on their doorway
and what are your thoughts on that
happens
we've heard from i have heard from
community members
and leaders this morning about the
impact
of the discharge of uh
rubber bullets and tear gas on
the nearby apartments and that is
something that is extremely concerning
to me
our city council obviously took the step
to pass a resolution
uh imploring the the brooklyn senate uh
police department to not use such
tactics uh
for and those are some of the reasons
why
our council took that step
so the folks in in in those apartments
are
you know have been impacted by the noise
uh by the gas
by the uh the rubber bullets and
we're actively working with community
based organizations to offer relief
uh to the people in those apartments uh
whether it's in the form of
food uh or or other needs uh
that that that may arise the sheriff is
in charge but
have you had conversations with him like
play off our people with that kind of
stuff
we certainly have had uh conversations
we've relayed
uh you know the
the resolution that the city council
passed we've conveyed
uh those sentiments uh to the sheriff's
office
and so they're well aware of uh
the position of brooklyn center at least
from the from the city council
standpoint
what's the city's role in operation
safety next
the city is a is a partner
to that operation like many other
law enforcement uh agencies
the crisis member teams to be paid and
why did the city feel necessary to hire
a pr
person the
the crisis yeah you can you can speak
today sure
the crisis commission um
team members are not paid their
volunteers and
they have been gracious enough to work
with us as a city to try to
um as we share a common goal of trying
to bring peace and be able to
protest peacefully and bridge new gaps
and build relationships with our city
as relates to uh public relations we do
need capacity
just the emails and phone calls from all
of you today and yesterday
is overwhelmed we're not a city of a
large metropolitan city
so we needed additional capacity it was
not from some particular angle of
something that we needed help
but we did need help and capacity is
coordinating our press conferences
according how we communicate with
residents coordinating how i communicate
with staff
coordinating how we communicate with a
various number of other organizations in
in groups so that's why we're simply
increasing our
has there capacity work to identify if
we are any groups
or specific individuals to try and
contact them directly
suffice it to say that the
law enforcement team that's assembled to
respond to this crisis
is working diligently to
identify agitators within the protest
because we know that there are a large
number of people who are
there to protest peacefully and to
express their grievance we know that
there are agitators that show up looking
to stir things up and to confront
and engage law enforcement in ways uh
that
the vast number of vast majority of
people who are
coming to the protest are not intending
uh to do so
pandemic why are people being taken to
jail for over 24 hours
i'm sorry can you repeat your question
i'm just saying it's the third wave
cases are increasing and we're hearing
about people being
kept in jail for over 24 hours
uh for coming to a protest after curfew
doesn't seem to quite match can you talk
about
the reasoning for that again so that is
a very
good question to ask the hennepin county
sheriff's office
as the leading agency in charge of the
operation
i share that i have a concern about that
as well
um about holding people uh
for that long during this pandemic
people who are out protesting obviously
they're engaged
in more violent acts uh than
you know uh other measures need to be
taken to make sure that they
the people who are engaging in in
violence are
uh you know um treated accordingly
but if people are out protesting
peacefully and they
their only crime is to be out past the
curfew
then it seems to me uh holding them in a
way that
puts them at risk of uh contracting the
virus or
uh spreading the virus unit pandemic
uh you know seems to to not match
with what our public uh health goals
would be
oh mr mayor answer that and one second i
want to get back to the question as
relates to
being able to identify those agitators
and i simply want to articulate
one of the advantages we are the fruits
of our
crisis management our crisis a community
crisis team at this point
we discussed that very point so
historically what happened
yesterday was that in identifying those
who may be
throwing a bottle of those someone who's
throwing a brick our police officers
were able to identify them
in a particular particular way i won't
say exactly how that's done but
nevertheless they were able to identify
them
but that that's only a few um so today
as we talked with community
leaders we talked about we know that
there are certain
organizations that are peacefully
organizing protesting
and so they're wearing something in
particular and so now
we've understand that so now polit
police officers know that when that
group shows up
that's one of the um groups that are
doing peaceful
protesting so it's not to say that
something can happen that
but the advantage is now the police can
take their focus
on a smaller group and begin to identify
who's working in a particular area
another is the communication in which i
shared with you earlier
as those community leaders are in the
crowd and they're able to communicate
being able to articulate to our police
officers relay that information
so those are two particular advantages
that we have today
that we didn't have yesterday as a
result of trying to work together with
community
so to your question mr mayor i won't
definitely answer that yeah
for those of you that got here late what
is the message you have for protesters
tonight
and could you suggest a question that
i'm
so while i answer that question first i
have
no no further comments on uh officer
potter's
current employment status with the city
but i i do i do want to
answer your question directly about my
message uh
to the to the protesters and to
reiterate it is this
all eyes uh of the world are on
brooklyn center and i want to urge you
all of us
i mean sorry all of you who are out to
protest peacefully
to do so without violence we need to
show
and we must show the very best of our
community
mr wright's family deserves that and so
we're asking
uh anyone who is coming out to protest
and protest peacefully
to also leave uh before the curfew
which is uh ten o'clock to six to six
a.m
uh today in brooklyn center
of this demonstration the way that
they're using pepper spray
pellets um and gas at times
you know the whole approach to policing
is there any democratic oversight
of this are they listening to you
let me be clear we must
first and foremost work to protect
the lives
of the folks in our community we must
first
work to secure the safety of our
community
and we have to do so using
the most or sorry using the the least
lethal force necessary
to make sure that we're protecting our
community
and we're protecting our livelihoods
i stand with the position of my city
council which is
that uh we we we have to
um we have to approach policing
in a different way in a more humane way
gassing in my opinion
is not in uh in a
humane way of uh
of policing
our police department and our officers
are not involved
in gassing no that's not what i asked i
said are they listening to you when you
say that they need to change
are they saying yes we will change or
are they ignoring
well um i guess the fact speaks for
themselves right
they're ignoring it why isn't that
member of uh
operation safety net here to answer some
of these questions because it seems like
that is what is in charge right now in
front of the police department to his
question about
whether or not they should be doing that
or not i feel like
it's difficult for you guys to answer
but uh the community and
those who would like to protest and as
was mentioned the majority who were
peaceful last night
may have been experiencing some of that
gas
again circling back i apologize for the
length why isn't a member of
operation safe and then not here to
answer some of these questions
that is a very important question again
i would direct those questions to the
sheriff's office
mayor the sheriff's office
they're all here as part of a mutual aid
process did you not
ask them to be here and to help what is
that mean how that works
i did initially ask for mutual aid
the operation last night was
uh under the auspices of the sheriff's
office
um and and that's all i'll say about
that
are you basically saying you have no
control over what's happening in the
city
i retain full control of my department
the operation
that took place last night was
completely under the auspices of the
sheriff's department
[Music]
have you asked them to leave you don't
condone what they're doing
have you asked them to leave
the sure the sheriff's uh to my
understanding the sheriff's department
has
uh policing powers uh
throughout throughout the county what do
you think about the national media's
lead multiple times
asking the media to leave demanding
demanding the media to leave is
absolutely
unequivocally unacceptable
i issue the curfew order in my curfew
order
permits the media
to be there past the 10 o'clock hour
the curfew does not apply to the media
didn't follow that they must follow that
do you plan to ask
law enforcement
well we're we're working to make sure
that
again we we have to protect the lives of
our citizens
and we have to uh work with our team to
make sure that we're formulating
uh a plan uh to secure that
and we and we're doing that however
however i
however what i will say is that
my to my understanding the sheriff's
office has policing powers uh throughout
the county
we're gonna take three or four more
questions guys during the curfew okay
at 10 o'clock and i got an emergency
notice on my phone
around nine o'clock letting me know to
leave the area because it's curfew but
it was originally set at 10 o'clock can
you describe
what happened there the
the emergency notice that went out to
cell phones
did not originate from our city and so
to my understanding i believe that is a
function of
uh the county okay but you're in charge
of setting the currency
absolutely is the city at all liable uh
for paying for
uh
any question one more time please uh is
is the city
paying in any way for former officer
part of
criminal defense
well the um officer pardon is no longer
an employee
of the city of brooklyn center so
should we be involved in a lawsuit then
we would have to cover
our liability whatever that may be but
we are not
in any way defending um officer parter
because she's not an employee of the
city of brooklyn center
two more questions guys two more
portland park did a 8 p.m curfew last
night we did
you did a 10 o'clock review curious why
not make it earlier since really bks
kind of started right around
the clock
well we are balancing
people's rights uh to to
peacefully assemble we're also
in the month of ramadan and people are
you know traveling uh back and forth
again
you know the the curfew order
does permit people to travel for work uh
for emergency
medical attention um
you know working with with our team we
determined that
10 o'clock would allow for people to
gather
but at the same time um
allow law enforcement to be able to uh
you know uh secure secure the
the safety and peace of of our community
now do you
think that this is a real democratic
crisis now you've made it clear here
today that you did not support the way
the demonstration was police last night
by the sheriff's department they
shouldn't have sent the media
away and they shouldn't have been using
pepper spray and gas
they're not listening to you this is a
crisis isn't it
you're the elected one absolutely
i want to be clear though my officers
our police department was not engaged
in using any uh pepper spray or gas
last night they were
um
there was a a number of our officers who
were
part of the operation however
the vast majority of our officers were
responding to 911 calls throughout the
city as well
well i mean our work uh is first and
foremost to secure the safety of our
community and we are doing that
uh
can you repeat that how can you deter
the safety of members of the city when
you can't control the
we're working uh still working
to try and work collaboratively
collaboratively with
all the law enforcement partners that
are engaged
in trying to secure the safety of our of
our community
being told to go home over a loudspeaker
telling the press to leave in front of
the performance
police department is there anything you
can do about that
i will see to it that the press is not
asked to leave
thank you everybody
right